[Music]
I lived in New York for years and I
think it has some of the best food in
the world I've invited my friend Harry
Kirsch over from the UK to teach him how
we do things slightly differently over
here we'll be visiting four of the top
rated Bagel spots across the city all in
one day to see if we can find New York's
best bagel this is Food Tours
our first stop of the day is that Utopia
bagels in Queens red Utopia bagels in
Queens on Utopia Parkway second best
Fountains of Wayne album and the reason
I took it here is because this place has
got Dynamite bagels and although we're
on the beaten paths so maybe not a lot
of tourists come out here don't get me
wrong buddy they make so many bagels
here over a hundred thousand a week
dude they go through two tons of flour
a day so many bagels do the oven they
got in there spent
1947 which of course was during World
War II just after yes so I figure for
the day every place we go we're getting
the traditional New York City Bagels and
locks perfect have you ever had Bagels
unlocks before I have in the UK we call
it a salmon and cream cheese bagel oh my
God
you have a lot to learn my friend what
do you think makes a good bagel so I'm
looking for a nice golden brown bagel I
want it seasoned on both sides so if we
got like everything bagel we need
toppings on the top and the bottom don't
be skimping on it crackly crust on the
outside nice and chewy inside and then
the toppings are going to be good as
well we need the salmon to be good the
cream cheese to be good okay great
everything's going to work together nice
I agree for me what I look for is what
tastes the best that helps on a food
show
some places attempted to just overfill
for the sake of overfilling it whereas
actually like I don't want that I'd
rather have like fewer toppings yeah and
therefore it holds together much better
when you eat it I want everything in one
bite so don't be stacking interesting
thing about bagels and locks which I've
heard before and I cannot confirm or
deny but it sounds like it's true and
that's all we need for the internet is
that bagels and locks became popular
because it was a reaction to eggs
benedict which wasn't kosher I am half
Jewish yeah have you ever gone kosher or
done anything no I'm not a very I'm not
a very good Jew I'm 50 Ashkenazi Jewish
which is the type of Jewish where we
kind of moved to Eastern Europe and then
many people then came to the US so
honestly they've kind of brought the
bagels with them yeah so I feel like I'm
experiencing like a spiritual homecoming
with this episode I'm very excited I'm
starving I'm so hungry all right hold
the table I'm gonna get some bagels I
got it
Mama there you go man look at this thing
look how much locks they gave us
thick doesn't look good right incredible
amount of locks as you can see
Capers cream cheese also got raw red
onion on there all on and everything
bagel First Impressions what do you
think this looks fantastic very like
pretty to look at like you say it's nice
generous with the salmon yeah I will say
the tomato
kind of Blends in with the salmon so for
a second I thought it was just like a
pure wedge of salmon some of it is
tomato that's pretty good still pretty
generous yeah I'm not complaining yeah
Bagels still look a little bit warm
which excites me a lot yeah you're
feeling fresh I mean these are straight
out of the oven the 1947 of them should
we give a try yeah oh yeah
oh man
crunch
that tastes like a bagel again over
there in London this is the first Bagel
I've had in New York and it already
might be better than any bagel I've had
in London believe it because I'm
thinking about the Capers and um
not really some delis might do it to
order I'll tell you the standard one in
the UK If you ask for like a bagel and
lox or a bagel with salmon and cream
cheese will just be salmon and cream
cheese without the onion without the
Tomato without the Capers is very much
just a plain sandwich but I'm liking all
these toppings I do think they work
together yeah it's great it seems I
would have never thought before having
this they're like fish for breakfast it
kind of turned me off but that's that's
amazing right yeah it's like so
delicious I'd say fish for breakfast
isn't something that's super uncommon to
Europeans I think in Jewish culture in
Eastern European culture and even in
Scottish culture like kippers for
breakfast you will find fish on the menu
at a breakfast place so that's not super
weird to us but yeah this really really
works yeah I was worried when I saw that
tomatoes in this generally speaking not
a huge fan of tomatoes and sandwiches
but this this really works right it's
actually got some crunch to it a little
bit of flavor yeah I think they've
actually seasoned it which is crucial
yeah as you can tell it's clutch for
places like this the fact that they make
the bagels they're just making them all
day so getting them right out of the
oven at other places they get them
that morning or the night before I mean
it's bigger this is amazing how great
these bagels are you can really really
taste the freshness you bite into it and
there's like steam coming out of it yeah
they're making 15 000 of these a day
that's so many right yeah it's a lot
that's really good to know that you can
come in pretty much any time of day and
get a fresh bagel though it does make a
difference yeah and anyone will tell you
the breakfast meal you got a pair with a
beverage I of course went with coffee
and you of course got
yeah how does that pair with the blue
Gatorade perfectly so well when in Rome
you know is this a European thing right
here Gatorade for breakfast this is not
no this is just me being a little bit
sleepy we're like pro athletes man we've
got to eat our way through New York
today we need as many electrolytes as we
can go yeah yeah I agree I will say I
think this is a very very good bagel it
had all the elements that I wanted the
bagel itself was fantastic crunchy on
the outside chewy on the inside
everything held together pretty well
yeah despite the fact that they were
they were generous but not too generous
they didn't stack they didn't stack no
stocking so yeah I think uh this might
be one to beat you know it's a good
start well I'm ready to hit it want to
go to the next place I think so let's go
our next location has been in the New
York Bagel game for over 32 years
Liberty Bagels
all right look at me
Liberty Bagel Queens not to be confused
with the location that's in Manhattan
this is the other one or the Statue of
Liberty
different place we're currently not
inside the Statue of Liberty I want to
make it clear of that I know
yep we're nowhere near it I don't think
this spot fantastic Bagels I love this
place also I noticed on the menu they
have a rainbow Bagel you probably saw
that all over the the grams of insta
yeah I mean I'm saying posters this is
the home of the rainbow Bagel were these
guys like one of the first to do it no
clue
kind of like how you see the scientists
like your best in New York City and the
bagel shops a lot of them were like home
of the rainbow Bagel we're definitely
another bagel with the locks of cream
cheese the Capers whole thing I also do
want to get a rainbow bagel for you to
try out I mean it's like uh it became a
New York City Institution for better for
worse so we'll get one of those as well
yeah the rainbow Bagel is kind of like a
2017 gimmick yeah but you know and
acrylic Insider specifically owns a lot
to that uh yes they do and I was part of
that and you're welcome and I'm sorry
whatever we can tell the viewers at home
we actually we have a conference room in
our office called rainbow Bagel that is
how deeply The Insider connection with
rainbow Bagels run so yeah I guess we
can try one of those as well the locks
is the main event yeah that'll be fun
too so I'm going out what's in the
picture right so for this one you want
to point out how scallions and scaling
and cream cheese a favorite of mine but
it does not have red onions okay okay
with that also comes on the poppy seed
bun so all urine tests are off good I
will not let anyone test my pee in the
next few days just to be on the safe
side yeah I'm excited pick this location
because like their other location in
Manhattan is considered
the best bagel in New York City by
TripAdvisor and I couldn't imagine it
tasting that much different there than
here okay good people Trip Advisor said
that Liberty bagels are number one we're
gonna see if uh Joey public knows her
stuff when it comes to Bagels then if
there's one thing I've learned in my
ears on this planet is that what
everyone says on the Internet is
probably correct all the time I think
that's absolutely true I like it in here
nice Vibe friendly stuff yeah I'm
excited to try the bagels
visualizing this my guy oh
they definitely made it more obvious
that the tomato and the and the salmon
are two different zones yeah this thing
distinct layers here again a lot of
people they think it's quality if it's
piled high in the fish you want
everything in one bite I don't want just
one bite of fish I don't want to OD on
the fish I want a taste of everything
quality over quantity yeah yeah it's
important I think proportion what and
very gentle the cream cheese also what I
like Capers and scallions and this thing
is covered in yeah
top and bottom yeah good coverage yeah
ready to jump in I'm so ready let's do
it let's go man
oh
mine just smoosh a little bit
a little bit of smushing I'm also
getting poppy seeds everywhere
Tomatoes good quite firm bites of the
Tomato the bagel's Fantastic The Bagel
is really good it's a fresh Bagel yep
I'd say maybe not they're like
crunchiest on the outside
but the inner texture is really really
good that's got that shoe that you know
and love
now that we've had a bite I want to say
that I'm a bit biased towards scallion
cream cheese and the scallion versus The
Red Onion sure I'm not saying that is my
favorite everywhere but I've known that
that made this more of an enjoyable bite
for me I do love red onions don't get me
wrong
scallions I like yeah I don't think I
like missed the red onion at all to be
honest unless because you're getting
that onioniness that savoriness from two
two locations yeah two ingredients
little one two one two allium punch
there's no lack of want
when it comes to any flavors is that
what I'm trying to say but I'm tasting
the least though is the fish I'm not
getting a lot of the salmon in here I
kind of disagree I feel like it's got a
reasonably strong flavor I don't know so
like in the UK If you ever get like a
salmon cream cheese bagel you're gonna
get smoked salmon
is that an everywhere thing in the US or
is that kind of optional okay yeah it's
a place of discretion I'm glad you asked
that so it's not always gonna be smoking
I don't think it's smoked here is it
maybe quite mildly definitely not like a
strong Smoky flavor
but I do think it's like got a good
flavor to it okay maybe it's getting
slightly lost in the scallion cream
cheese for example and like I said they
were quite generous on the Capers which
does mean that when you bite into one of
those for a second it's like boom that's
all you can taste I feel the Capers
stand out more in this one I'm not quite
sure why or how I feel about that I
think in general the ratio is pretty
good though I'm not I'm not that mad
about the ratio look at the cream cheese
man yeah yeah they're generous to cream
cheese which is nice but that's making a
squishy man you're squishing I like
quite like when you get a green cheese
and it's quite sour and a bit Tangy but
it looks like this one's more like on
the mild creamy side that's really funny
because I'm the exact opposite I want I
want the cream cheese to be like just
fine because to me I want the bagels to
be the start of the show right so is
this more up your street than you're
quite happy with the way that this cream
cheese works I am as far as the way the
cream cheese does or does not stand out
I think I'm just I'm like a Savory onion
I'm an oniony boy sure all right my
Persona is just onion so you're an
oniony boy I think but I like a Tang boy
I would say I'm more of a Tangy I want a
bit of time for the cream cheese the
Capers I like extra Tang you know yeah
yeah I couldn't stop myself man I
couldn't stop myself
it was a good bagel rip the last place
we have to go to because you're just
gonna be how is it fine let's go home
all right you couldn't come to New York
without trying a rainbow Bagel hang on I
didn't say the rainbow bagel's good sure
it just became uniquely New York for uh
maybe the wrong reasons it was a viral
sensation so here we go well and also
there we go we got sweet birthday cake
Cup oh that's like vibrant I know all
right
look at this thing all of those colors
are found in the UK yeah you're gonna
eat this and then be like really
aggressive for some unknown reason all
right you can't get this red in here so
you said you've had this before yeah I
have and this is the birthday cake cream
cheese one more food coloring for him
again I can't say I'm thrilled about
this but let's give it a try
you know the frosting
look at like a bagel of frosting I don't
actually hate it as much as I thought I
would
it's like a dessert baby frosting it's
like a slice of cake I certainly
couldn't handle one in the morning I
certainly would not be like having that
on the way to work I'll walk into the
office like flipping tables let's go
like that Sugar High would just get
right go right to my brain and then 20
minutes later asleep at my desk yeah
Americans love dessert for breakfast you
do don't we you guys love pancakes
waffles Donuts cereal is like really
sweet right so I don't know if you can
really draw the line at a rainbow bagel
with cream cheese but I will say texture
on this Bagel really good I would say
this one has maybe even more uh this one
might have even more of a kind of crispy
outside than what than the previous one
we just tried so if you if you were to
order again you'd get this with the
rainbow bagel no I think maybe I just
hope that they had a fresh poppy seed
cleanse my palette with a real bagel
got some Savory back in you a couple of
Keepers all right back online what time
you always my man ready for next bagel I
am yeah can we run there so that I can
burn off this energy hype that was a
plan cool Sweet let's go
foreign
immediately not working
from Queens we made our way into
Manhattan to continue our Bagel tour
next up Tompkins Square Bagels
I wear Tompkins Square Bagels right by
the Tompkins Square in the East Village
this place is amazing also another spot
that does the kettle boil for the bagels
I haven't explained it to you yet I will
now take the dough throw in some boiling
water before the bacon it gives it like
the outside of it that really nice crisp
almost crackery crust nice all I know
about this place is that it's Timothy
chalamet's favorite Bagel in New York
and who is that he's a guy okay
hit me with some Bagel all right
Bagel facts you ready I'm sorry all
right created by Eastern European Jewish
communities originated in Poland there's
food often given to women in childbirth
the circle shape represents life cycle
and good luck there you go truly is
everything in a bagel you know
yeah out
and in reference to the whole circle of
life or death and everything everywhere
all at once yes I'm The Lion King if
there's Bagels in The Lion King no but
that's the circle of life ah yeah close
enough but there's everything bagel and
everything and we're all at once there
is correct everything I just made the
connection to see everything
uh I can't help but I can't watch
anything without like having two other
screens in front of me if you like
Family Guy Clips yeah
yeah I got it until they got it I got
the gist that's right man it's been what
like an hour since we last ate a bagel
it's about you but I'm starving I could
go for a bagel right now
yeah
[Music]
there it is
I think it's stuck
thank you here we go all right so I
don't know notice but this one has got a
lot of stuff so this is a packed out
bagel cream cheese Sesame Bagel Capers
capers
it's got all the uh all the key elements
it's got the sesame seeds on the top and
the bottom yep you've mentioned that
before we like oh the stuff's not tap
and the bottom like it always is it not
like that in the UK not really no no so
you get a bagel it's just on the top I
mean Sesame Bagels aren't even that
common some of them will be I feel like
if you do get one often just on one side
that's not normal very hard to come by
in everything bagel in the UK as well
yeah so in terms of the actual Bagel
options we're pretty limited whereas
over here you guys have got it figured
out this is beautiful I just kind of
want to stare at this for a bit longer
before I will say I said it before and I
say it again
it's an aggressively stacked Bagel which
makes it harder to get everything on one
bite we'll see how it holds up I think
do they think mine bar is I mean I've
got a pretty big mouth so I'll be fine
but yeah not me though good luck all
right
okay
[Music]
cream cheese is definitely hidden the
Salmon's fantastic
now first time we've done Sesame bagel
I'm liking it the bagel itself excellent
yeah so like Crispy Crunchy on the
outside
yeah and a good amount of like
sponginess on the inside oh my God and
red onion this is like the onion
onioniest one we've had this is a berry
onion I'm not complaining
I want to take just a little bit of the
salmon and just try that on its own as
well
so I get more of a smoked salmon flavor
from that yeah which personally I love
that's what I'm used to in the UK If you
get something like this it's generally
going to be smoked yeah avastika adds
such a lovely flavor
we might just go on Sideways over here
but yeah
I'm going in I'm going back in oh
when I get everything in a bite
fantastic I'm really impressed with the
bagel and all the bagels we've had maybe
the Crispies on the outside yeah the
crackle as you bite into that from the
outside yeah it's so satisfying it's uh
it's onion overload which might be
overshadowing the locks ever so slightly
I got so much in my teeth right now
that's the downside to sesame seeds
show me the monitor oh God
I got it one of my few complaints about
this is that maybe they've done a little
bit too much
it's like a slightly messy this was the
original Xbox thickness of bagel
stacking today and I get it some people
they're like yeah I want to lie one
thing I wanted you to try they have here
is how can I put this pastrami locks so
those are two words that don't really
exist in the UK figure out a way to make
them together you want to check it out
absolutely
it's salmon that is prepared like
pastrami they got the pepper crust
right okay get a hold of that so as
someone who's kind of like
as someone who's uh pretty new to
pastrami
what types of flavors can I be expecting
here this is the pastrami rubs it's
gonna be very pepper happy
but like kind of like a smokiness to it
I think that's where you get the smoking
is from because this was this does smell
like it's been smoked sure
but that's not the exact
salmon that we've had on the bagel right
so it's different
oh this is so good
mmm this is so good it does have like a
pastrami flavor to it right it does
weird how they did that this is going to
be a slight insult to pastrami but the
thing it reminds me of is almost like a
hot dog flavor like the Frankfurter kind
of seasoning okay I get that I will say
this is nicer than a hot dog it's
fantastic I mean I want to have more but
I think you guys should try some of this
let's do Connor first and then yeah
let's get uh rip a bong hit on there
right that's just exactly pastrami
you're next
thank you hot dog yeah thank you I would
be really tempted to try that on my
bagel instead of just a standard locks
that go go put it on there remake it
yeah
don't get too full on bagelness we got
another spot to go to and I don't know
about you but I'm hungry for bagels baby
I could eat and almost infinite number
of bagels yeah so let's go let's go
thank you
our fourth and final stop was to a New
York Bagel staple since 1976. Essa bagel
this might be the most localist
favoritest spots very nice uh and the
most historic it's been here since the
70s started by an Austrian family they
have a bunch of locations now this isn't
the first one it's a nice spot yeah a
lot of real estate here yeah right by
Penn Station very convenient to get to
all right I want to see what the babies
are like
last one of the day there you go here we
go
baby okay oh my I want to call to your
attention go on the first and only
appearance of lettuce in our Bagels in a
bagel is this common obviously I guess
not because it hasn't been in any of the
other places how do you feel about
lettuce in a bagel I can't imagine the
lettuce swaying my opinion too much on
it I don't think but I don't know I
reserve That official POV until after I
bite into this yeah I think like maybe
this has one of the higher filling to
bread ratios that we've had so far oh
yeah this thing is like almost entirely
filling not a ton of bagels not
complaining there we go bite go all
right man
oh
I was wrong I can really taste the
lettuce on this
you do get the letters now okay
all the letters are coming out
the lettuce has been removed
I will say we've had a lot of bagels
today
and I feel like both of us are still
devouring these so make it that way you
will okay points out for the lattice but
everything else
really generous with you with the locks
and sugar yeah
I was thickly cut the salmon tastes
fresh yeah not like in your face fishy
but like you can taste it which is good
I really love the thick locks I'm really
impressed with it
I put this cream cheese again at like
the kind of gentler end of the scale
which I know you've kind of suggested
that you like you don't know what
they're like too much of a yeah yeah
the cook on the bagel is great you see
these like little kind of like blistery
bits yeah you can tell it's been kettled
gets that real nice crust on the outside
yeah if I was to get this again don't
put lettuce anywhere near my bagel it's
enough of biting something everything's
going this way I think lettuce is like
the uh the uh emulsifier of that it's
just like it might just like this is
like I boys we're out of here yeah it's
like when you uh try and like pull the
tablecloth out from the table and
everything just comes off with it yeah I
feel like that's the effect that the
lettuce is having it's a much better
analogy
um overall really good really good
overall still a very good bagel now is
the part
of the episode where we do the thing
that we always do at the end it's true
we're gonna decide who had the best
bagel all right for me I was looking for
a combination of everything in a bite
right so I was not very happy with
stacking in some of these places
obviously there's a bagel places every
Bagel had to be nice and pillowy but
also crispy in the outside I think
almost every Bagel we had today was
fresh right I don't recall disliking any
of the locks at any other place we've
been to do you no I think we've had
varying levels of like smokiness versus
just straight Lots flavor but overall I
think I agree yeah like we've had fresh
Bagels high quality ingredients yeah
pretty much across the board it's a
difficult decision I would say broadly
I've had some of the best bagels of my
life today when have you had a better
Bagel than the bagels the other day and
what city where you went I don't think I
have okay I do think that on average
these definitely outrank UK Bagels
unfortunately yeah I'd say so too
whether it's the tap water
famous New York tap water or something
else but I wish that we could take these
Bagels
and make them in the UK because I would
be eating these
so often it's amazing right yeah really
amazing I'll just go and say it right
now then my favorite Bagel today was I'm
going to make before too I'm just gonna
pick tamping Square nice yeah there was
just something about the bagel on The
Lox everything works so well together I
mean we're really talking about out of
all four of them we're talking
millimeters better as far as like
however we're ranking them we're
measuring that but
so my Tomkins was just like now the
Vietnam had a chance to think about it
fantastic bag also Charlemagne knows his
stuff huh yeah that's right Shelly Boy
again it's like there's a hair in this
yeah
I think it's Utopia for me wow okay all
right I mean those were really those
were fresh yeah it was the fact that
they had just come out of the oven
they're churning out fresh Bagels yeah
all throughout the day yeah you can go
in there pretty much anytime breakfast
lunch dinner and get a hot fresh bagel I
think the ratio of fillings was good
yeah ingredients were good quality yeah
everything in that Bagel just worked for
me okay and I think it was excellent
considering that we've eaten quite a lot
of bagels today I'm still feeling pretty
good I am stuffed to the gills I'm never
eating again
foreign